[Música]
a la edad de 10 años tuvo que dejar
hervir name en una barcaza de migrantes
fue acogida en Canadá y allí desarrolló
todo tipo de actividades desde ser una
traductora hasta una exitosabogada y
luego pasando por ser la dueña de un
restaurante y además una gran chef esto
antes de desarrollar su talento como una
autora aclamada internacionalmente por
su visión literaria de lo que es la
migración Empezando por la propia
historia Vamos a abordar lo que más
podamos de sus libros Aunque seguro que
no nos va a alcanzar el tiempo
vi una mujer minúscula Man y en títulos
que definitivamente deberían Buscar en
las librerías Así que
bienvenida France 24 Muchas gracias por
la invitación perdón se me mezclaron los
idiomas no no hay problema hablas inglés
vietnamita francés
español todavía no Pero pronto espero
que pronto
[Música]
hablemos de Ruth porque se siente como
una recopilación de historias cortas
como tus otros libros a mí me parece
como un viaje por diferentes episodios
de memoria quiero preguntarte primero
por qué elegiste escribir de esta manera
y segundo también me resulta Interesante
como pasas de un personaje a otro porque
nos deja saber lo justo para sentirnos
sobrecogidos por ellos
y luego los dejas ir eso eso me impacta
Porque quiero saber más pero así es como
la mayoría de personas pasan por nuestra
vida hablemos de eso
me gustaría poder decirte cómo o por qué
los escribí en pequeñas historias
pero en realidad no lo sabía empecé a
escribir porque muchas veces me quedaba
dormida en los semáforos en rojo y
cuando uno se queda dormido en los
semáforos en rojo puede tener un
accidente Porque el pie se aligera
suelta el freno entonces una forma de
mantenerme despierta en los semáforos
fue empezar a tomar notas Así que
probablemente el tiempo que duran las
historias es el tiempo que duran los
semáforos en rojo
tal vez no sé pero así es como empecé a
escribir
y bueno cuando uno cuenta la historia de
una persona uno dice ah pero esa persona
es amiga de esa otra y empieza a
explicar cómo están relacionados esos
personajes como un sistema Exacto
Entonces no elegí saltar de una persona
a otra se hablara de ti por ejemplo
tendría que hablar de France 24 cuando
conocí a alguien en París o algo así
entonces sucede naturalmente sí como una
conversación en un bar te sientas y
empiezas a hablar y luego una historia
lleva a la otra Bueno tengo que decir
que funciona muy bien
sí funciona Sí sí al menos para mí
Parece como Si pensara en muchas cosas
al mismo tiempo No para nada
continuando quiero hablar de la
migración porque ya no es algo
sorprendente
este problema está en las noticias todos
los días está en las calles lo vemos en
todas partes
pero no entendemos realmente lo que pasa
por la cabeza de un migrante algunos de
nosotros privilegiados no vemos todo lo
que deberíamos ver de esta situación
entonces en qué crees que deberíamos
concentrarnos cuando hablamos de
migración
hay dos problemas verdad porque los
medios de comunicación son los que dicen
cómo son los migrantes y los medios
dicen que los migrantes son malas
personas que intentan cruzar fronteras
ser ilegales y cosas así pero hace 44
años cuando salí de Vietnam los medios
decían algo muy diferente decían que los
migrantes eran personas muy valientes
que habían dejado a los comunistas para
llegar a países libres y entonces Canadá
Francia Australia Estados Unidos todos
abrieron sus brazos para decir queremos
que vengan a nuestro país
O sea que es una narrativa Sí sí ningún
inmigrante quiere abandonar su hogar su
identidad su cultura a propósito A menos
que se vea obligado a hacerlo
hermoso y la mayoría de las personas que
se van saben que la muerte Los está
esperando porque tendrán que cruzar el
océano tendrán que caminar se
encontrarán con muros se encontrarán con
la policía y todo eso Y saben que el 99%
de las veces no lo lograrán pero aún así
se van por qué Porque no les queda otra
opción
y Alguien que ha sobrevivido a todo esto
se convierte en un súper atleta en un
súper humano
si yo dirigiera un país los aceptaría a
todos porque son los más fuertes de
todos pero necesitamos oír más sobre sus
historias cuando se le da un micrófono a
un migrante nunca
nunca verdad
y por eso intento contar historias de
migrantes para recordar que yo también
fui migrante
y conectar sí y en un país como Canadá
los canadienses me miran y dicen Así es
verdad que fuiste migrante y después de
40 años Esto es lo que puede llegar a
ser un migrante el tipo de contribución
que le puede hacer a la sociedad así que
todo depende de la narrativa como lo
mencionaste anteriormente de cómo lo
decimos Cómo contamos la historia
Gracias por eso
el amor no siempre es un gesto universal
Tú escribes sobre la interpretación
vietnamita del amor
en tus libros dices que nace en la
cabeza Pero tú vives en Canadá y además
eres chef y también tu trabajo toca
muchos idiomas
Así que quiero preguntarte cómo
concilias hoy en día todas esas
expresiones tan diferentes
todas tan importantes y todas también
expresadas en los libros
conciliar
es como tener una caja de colores
entre más colores tengas más matices le
puedes dar a tu dibujo cierto
Entonces si Solo tienes azul y azul
oscuro es muy difícil crear matices
pero si tienes diferentes mundos como la
cultura de Vietnam y también la cultura
en Canadá la cultura francesa en Canadá
y la cultura inglesa en Canadá Entonces
tienes más colores así que puedes tener
más matices y tienes más complejidades
en lo que estás diciendo porque no estás
comparando solo un mundo con otro
sino que los tienes a todos entrelazados
danzando juntos es como la comida si
Solo tienes sal y pimienta es muy
aburrida necesitas cilantro necesitas
jalapeños necesitas aguacate necesitas
todo eso para darle sabor al plato
Bueno ya que hablamos de comida pues
Sigamos hablando de comida porque leer
Man me hizo dar hambre de verdad
sí
de verdad de verdad seguro que no soy la
primera que te lo dice pero es muy
especial saborear el amor saborear los
recuerdos y la añoranza a través de tus
recetas o de las recetas de tus
personajes en cuanto a ti Cuál es el
efecto de la comida vietnamita
sabes que la comida Nunca es solo comida
verdad la comida transmite una cultura
no solo una cultura sino geografía y la
forma en que cocinamos la forma en que
expresamos el amor en Vietnam nadie
pregunta
cómo te sientes estás triste estás feliz
nunca decimos eso solo decimos tienes
hambre quieres más comida cuando vas a
casa de alguien no te preguntan Cómo
estás te preguntan si ya comiste y te
dan comida entonces la comida es una
expresión de amor
No solo eso sino que justo aquí en
Colombia para mí probar la papaya y que
supiera Exactamente igual que en Vietnam
tan dulce y Tropical lo mismo pasa con
la piña en Canadá no sabe igual porque
viaja y no tiene el sabor del sol
aquí las frutas saben a calor a sol a
Trópico
traen tantos recuerdos y acabo de
encontrar mangostino que también lo
tenemos en Vietnam
Y pensé esto es Vietnam
me conmueve profundamente la forma en
que evocas la maternidad como tu madre
cómo las madres de tus personajes y tú
misma como madre están siempre presentes
en las historias siempre están
observando siempre están siendo un punto
clave por qué
la maternidad pienso que la maternidad
me ha enseñado humildad cuando uno tiene
hijos sabe que ya no tiene ningún
control sobre ellos ni sobre el mundo
porque uno a sus hijos quiere darles el
mejor mundo posible
pero no puede no puede controlarlo así
que todo lo que uno puede hacer es
darles herramientas a sus hijos para que
puedan arreglarselas para que puedan
crecer y vivir en entornos que a veces
pueden ser muy hostiles
por eso para mí la crianza no solo la
maternidad
la crianza necesita mucha observación
pero no solo eso sino casi sentir dolor
todos los días porque uno ama tanto a
sus hijos y sabe que no puede
protegerlos tanto como quisiera
tengo un hijo autista que no puede
hablar
que no es verbal que solo posee 10
palabras mientras yo amo las palabras
quisiera dárselas a él pero él no puede
absorber todo lo que puedo darle
por eso tengo que ser humilde y entrar
en su cerebro para ver qué puedo darle
sabes
y Cómo puedo hacer que él sea tan feliz
como sea posible
de la manera en que es y no en la forma
que yo quiero que él sea entonces la
humildad la maternidad es cuestión de
humildad
bueno se nos está acabando el tiempo no
sé cuánto de ti hay realmente
pero quiero preguntarte algo porque el
personaje de Ruth siempre dice una cosa
especial sobre los viajes
Así que Mi pregunta es Cuántas maletas
trajiste a Bogotá y qué libros trajiste
solo traje una maleta pequeña
nunca más de ocho kilos incluyendo la
maleta la ropa los zapatos todo porque
necesito moverme muy rápido así que
nunca tengo una maleta grande un libro
no recuerdo el nombre es de una chica de
17 años que acaba de escribir su primer
libro
y vive en los suburbios en Francia y
Aparentemente su lenguaje Es hermoso la
belleza las palabras todo y no he tenido
tiempo de abrirlo
es un libro nuevo y todavía está en la
cama no lo he abierto
así son las cosas Tú misma lo dijiste
porque en rubble el personaje expresa
algo como que no hay que llevar mucho
equipaje solo las cosas necesarias en la
vida te
ayudo
Porque cuando uno llega con demasiado
equipaje siento que no puedo abrirme al
lugar en el que estoy
cuando no tienes demasiado equipaje y
por ejemplo hay una piscina y se te
olvidó llevar el traje de baño vas y
buscas uno
[Música]
y entras en la vida cotidiana del lugar
donde estás
Entonces La idea es cargar el menor peso
posible sobre ti para que puedas volar
para que puedas ser libre en el lugar
donde estás
sin mucho más que decir gracias Kim
Muchas gracias